hello everyone I hope you're all doing
great and I don't know how many of you
are actually following the protests lead
but those of you who do probably already
know this those of you who don't a
member of the Pittsburgh pawn grabbers
America's newest grandmaster a
wonderland has defeated Fabiano Caruana
and Hikaru Nakamura in the protest
League so this is one of the games I
decided to show you it's his games game
against Caruana with the white pieces
and although it's a pretty standard rule
opus I wonder really shows that there's
still a lot of poison to the real opus
and even a player of kiwanis caliber
can't really afford to be reckless so
let's see this game lien opens with E 4
we have E 5 93 96 and Bishop to b5 so
the real opus a6 the Murphy's defense a4
Knight to f6
we have castles Bishop to e7 and rook to
e1 so all standard Theory b5 Bishop to
b3 b6 now C 3 we have castles h3 Knight
to a5 Bishop to c2 all still a standard
line of the Morpheus defense c5 d4
Knight to d7 and here we have the block
in d5 Caruana goes for knife to b6 and
Knight B to d2 Bishop to d7 b3 now c4
Knight to f1 and night to b7 Bishop to
e3 C capture some b38 capture some b 3
and a 5 so leah has the open a file and
the Caruana
has the a pond and the be pond so he
will definitely try at some point to
push a for to create a passed pawn on
the Queen side Bishop to d3 by Lee and
preparing Queen to e2 to gain a double
attack on the b5 pawn so a 4 by Caruana
and now B for not allowing this exchange
rook to c8 and queen to e2 now offering
up the c3 pawn but in exchange
liyan will grab the b5 phone and then
the a 4 point will become a weakness so
Corona doesn't doesn't want to do this
he plays it Knight to c4
this blocks the Queens and bishops
attached to the b5 pawn and
so Corona wants to grab the bishop on e3
denying le and the bishop pair and here
lien goes for Bishop to c1 he wants to
preserve his bishop pair and later will
he play Knight to d2 and exchange this
Knight and c4 and then once again go
after the b5 pawn another idea instead
of Bishop to see one would be to play
Knight 3 to D to immediately go after
this night on c4 and actually allow nice
captures on a3 Knight captures and now
after rook tetras and c3 Bishop captures
and after Bishop to g5 now capture on d7
Queen captures and then play Queen to a6
now this pawn on e4 is still a is still
a pretty big weakness and he early and
would also win a pawn so this would be
another way to go about this but after
c4 he doesn't want to give up the bishop
pair Bishop c1 Queen to e8 now the Queen
and Bishop are both defending the b5
pawn and now Knight 3 to d2 offering an
exchange and Knight back to b6 now we
have ninth to be one defending the c3
pawn and here Fabiano plays at five we
have he captures on f5 and Bishop
captures on i-5 given up the pawn on d5
so pawn captures and now Queen to g6 and
Queen to g6
actually there's a double attack on the
night and b1 so this is the idea of
Queen to g6 and also now Fabiana will
capture the pawn on d5 with his knight
as you can't prevent both threats so
Bishop to e3
now both rooks are defending the knight
on b1 and now Fabiano simply captures
back the pawn Knight captures on d5 we
have Knights g3 attacking the bishop and
Bishop captures on b1 and here lien
plays Bishop to c4 pinning this night he
doesn't want to capture this piece he
wants to capture this piece now he pins
it and this is where Fabiano goes wrong
the best way for him to retreat this
position is actually to grab this bishop
on c4 with rook captures and after Queen
characters play Queen to d3
offering an exchange of Queens
the Queen has nowhere to go the point is
preventing her from going to be three
bishop is covering a 2 so you either
have to move the Queen to let's say C 6
or if you exchange them after Bishop
captures it's a pretty it's a pretty
it's a pretty good position for black
having having two pieces for the rook so
definitely definitely what Fabiano
should have gone for at after this
Bishop to c4 move but instead of
capturing here Fabiano plays Bishop 3
for getting his own piece out of the way
and he is up a piece now but you you
can't keep this piece as we have Queen -
8 - na mele and has a double attack on
the d5 Knight and there is no way to
protect it the Queen can protect it with
Queen to f7 or Queen to b6
but then the bishop on e4 is unprotected
as the knight will capture it so Fabiano
here plays King to h8 now we have Bishop
captures and Bishop captures and Queen
captures with an attack on the b7
night-night to d8 and now comes rook
captures on a4 here Olien grabs upon
he's up upon and is ready to push his
beep on up the board 9 3 6 we have B 5
he doesn't really care about his C pawn
he wants to start pushing his pawn
so rook captures on c3 with a b 6r up to
d3 attacking the Queen and Queen to b5
now kind of attacking the rook ok the
Queen does defend it but it's an the
pain is nicely placed behind the passed
pawn so Queen to e8 offering a trade of
Queens and this favors Liang so Queen
captures rook captures and rook to be
one not placing a rook behind the passed
pawn Knight to c5 attacking the rook
rook to a7 preparing the pond to be
pushed to b7
we have d5 corona also has a - passed
pawns in the center ok the D pawn is
past but this me point is much more
powerful
b7 now the threat of course is rook to
a8 just simply trading rook and
promoting to a queen and Knight capture
some b7 you have
give up a piece here rook captures and
now Bishop to a fate protecting the g7
pawn Knight to f5 now we have d4 Bishop
to g5 and now II for Fabiano will now
try to create a passed pawn of his own
Knight captures on g7 and now rook to d1
check King to h2 and now Bishop to d6
check g3 blocking and now rook to f8
with the threat of rook captures on f2
rook to f7 stopping this rook captures
rook captures and now comes King to g8
attacking the rook on f7 rope to d7
attacking the bishop and here we have
III here Fabiano offers a full piece
here would be idea that if rook captures
in captures on f2 threatening f1
promotion but then simply rook to f6
Queen is promoted on f1 rook captures
rook captures and here each player has
two pawns and Fabiano has a rook against
the bishop in the night white is better
here but this would give him drawing
chances so after e3 Liang isn't
interested in grabbing a piece instead
he plays Knight to h5 and it seems like
Fabiano
caught up right here it seems like pawns
to e2 and the pawn is unstoppable coming
to e1 problem is if you push e 2 you're
getting checkmated because of Knight to
f6 check doesn't matter what you play
flicking to f8 you get Bishop to h6
checkmate and if you go Bishop to King
to h8 you get rook captures on h7 again
this is checkmate
so after this night to h5 unfortunately
you can't push e 2 for being played
Bishop to e5 getting this Bishop out of
the way and preventing the knight from
going to f6 with check so F captures
only three now again you can't capture
because your rock is hanging on d1 so d3
pushing that passed pawn Knight Knight
to f6 check Bishop captures Bishop
captures and now rope to f1 attacking
the bishop Bishop g5 we have grouped to
have to check and after King to g1 the
rock is attacked there's really nothing
for Fabiano to do here anymore so in
this position
Fabiano Caruana resigned the game and a
very nice victory for the youngest
American Grandmaster and the newest I
believe I want early in here so that's
the game I think this is the first game
I've shown from the pro chesley and I
believe the third game I've shown by I
wonder League on my channel so I do hope
you enjoyed it I don't know if I will be
showing that game between Nakamura but I
might and I believe today is Nakamura
versus cross and the Fisher random match
so I'm pretty sure I'm gonna be enjoying
that and maybe I'll show again from that
match as well if there will be some
interesting games as Fischer random is
always interesting so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Mario Encinos Anand Rao
Kristian stork and Michael keen for a
contribution to my channel thanks a lot
to really appreciate it as usual you can
check to my previous videos here thank
you all for watching and I will still
see you soon and I'm still taking
suggestions what to do for a give away
when my channel reaches 100,000
subscribers thank you all and I'll see
you soon